السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته السلام
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله الا الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان
محمد رسول
الله حي على الصلاه
حي على
[Silence]
الصلاه حي على الفلاح
حي على
الفلاح الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور
انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل
فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله صلى الله عليه وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون يا يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث
منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا سديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله
ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم وشر الامور محدثاتها وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار
اخوتي في
الله قال
سبحانه احسب الناس ان يتركوا ان يقولوا
امنا وهم لا
يفتنون ولقد فتنا الذين من قبلهم فلا
يعلمن الله الذين صدقوا ولا يعلمن
الكاذبين نعلم بهذه الايه بقول الله
سبحانه وتعالى
ان هذه الحياه ستكون مليئه بالفتن ونحن
كمسلم الله سبحانه وتعالى يهيئ في هذه
الحياه فلن
تجد من غير
المسلمين شخصا قد تعلق قلبه في هذه الحياه
ان يتكلم عن
الموت او
يتكلم عن
شيء بغير زينه هذه
الحياه يتكلمون
فقط عما يزيد اموالهم
وملذات في هذه
الحياه مشتتين انفسهم
واذهل عما سيقبل
وهو
الموت يخاف الانسان من المستقبل ويهيئ
نفسه بما يعلم في هذه الدنيا وما يتعلمون
في هذه
الدنيا الا ما يزيد من
ملذاتهم
ولكن ترى ان المسلم
الذي تعلق قلبه
بالقران الذي تعلم من قول الله سبحانه
وتعالى قوي
القلب لا يتشتت ب ملهيات هذه
الدنيا والله سبحانه وتعالى كما قال
في
الايه التي
تلينا ان هذه الدنيا ستكون مليئه
بالفتن
والاختبارات وستكون ملاى
بالزينه كما قال سبحانه
وتعالى انا جعلنا ما على الارض زينه لها
لنبلوهم ايهم احسن
‏as
muslims and and also non muslims we face
sickness l of
wealth the passing of led
ones these are reminders that
لا نملك من هذه الحياه
شيء كما يذكرنا الله سبحانه وتعالى في
القران الله
‏when we re
blessings
and when we
face some
people ang they
something
they
why
beli that me
الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله
are hees
‏mercy years
[Silence]
‏brothers and few years
ag the earthquakes in
tury and those who have been tested
for far
beyond far beyond what we have
experienced we have seen people who l
their
hes their famili
‏war
like
tur
الحمدله الحمدله
‏when
they some
houses
الحمدله لا اله الا
الله الحمدله
الله سبحانه
وتالى
قران الله سبحانه
life life
‏we worship
him
so
الحد
allor and that the real re
is in
the one man his entire
family was left with only his daughter
الحمد the
bl another woman
was
r
days was saved first
first لا اله الا الله
‏is no
allah what me be
serv
when
ex we
ask we truly appreciate bls
of that given to
us do we only foc on we don't
have we
‏js thinking we
life
forting الحمد
لله الله سبحانه
وتالى chose usas
[Silence]
ع الله سبحانه
وتالى
in
some up
الله سبحانه
وتى
الله and very
easy not
a
un our hearts are att
life ours are
att ‏to the
money or the work or the
jobs that we
think going to give us something this
life and
worshipping our bosses or the work we
doing easy as that you just change your
intention and
ع الحمدله
الحمد
لله الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران
ولنبلونكم بشيء من الخوف والجوع ونقص من
الاموال والانفس والثمرات
وبشر الصابرين
الذين اذا اصابتهم مصيبه قالوا انا لله
وانا اليه راجعون
[Silence]
‏thees اللهد
الله سبحانه
وتالى his a ands prepare
ourselves to that
day patience is not
simply silent
durs but rather
اللهث اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور والبرحي
[Silence]
الحمد
لله الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على اشرف
الانبياء
والمرسلين سيدنا محمد عليه وعلى اصحابه
افضل الصلاه واتم
التسليم اخوتي في
الله عندما
نتذكر اننا عباد
لله ان الله سبحانه وتعالى
خلقنا لعبادته
وان الله سبحانه
وتعالى اعطانا ما لم يعطي احدا من خلقه
وقد بارك
فينا
ورفعنا عن شتى
مخلوقاته ندرك انه مهما
عملنا فلن نعبد الله حق عبادته ولن نشكره
حق
شكره و قد نستحي من الله سبحانه
وتعالى نستحي من ان
نطلبه ما لا نستحق ولكن سبحان
الله يرى بعضنا
كمسلمين
انه عندما نعبد
الله فمن المفروض ان يكافئ
فيرى
البعض انه عندما نصلي فيبارك الله في
اموالنا وسيزيد
منها وهذا ليس بشرط من شروط العباده
او لم يذكره الله سبحانه وتعالى لنا
كمسلمين بل
الاسلام هو ان تسلم لله سبحانه وه وتى
[Silence]
وتعبده
deserve per heal and
froms just by
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سحانه
وتالى الله سبحان
وتى الله
‏if he gives
us it is from his
mercy if he takes us
away it is from
his the real
success is
totient
and we have to ourselves
constant and not forget that this world
is a
‏pery no need
forn great
re الله قران ان مع العسر
يسرى ان مع العسر
يسرى
indeed
الله focus on what you have not what you
‏make from
اللهد gu us
toe
open gr
us and difficulties and gratitude ease
make us among those
[Silence]
اللهم امام حسن
محد
دعاء اللهم اغفر له وارحمه
وعافه وعف عنه واكرم نزله ووسع مدخله
واغسله بالماء والثلج والبرد ونقه من
الذنوب والخطايا كما ينقى الثوب الابيض من
الدنس والبس وابدله دار خيرا من داره
واهلا خيرا من اهله وزوجا خيرا من زوجه
وقه فتنه القبر وعذاب النار اللهم اغفر
لحينا وميتنا وشاهدنا و غائبنا وصغيرنا
وكبيرنا وذكرنا وانثانا اللهم من احييته
منا فاحييه عن الاسلام و ومن توفيته منا
فتوفه على الايمان اللهم لا تحرمنا اجرهم
ولا ت ولا تظلنا
بعده عبد
المجيد عبد
الكمال هيز
دعا اللهم رب الناس اذهب الباس اشفي انت
الشافي لا شفاء الا شفاءك شفاء لا يغادر
سقما اللهم عافه في بدنه اللهم عافه في
سمعك اللهم عاف في بصرك لا اله الا انت
اللهم سهل امره ويسر سر عمليته وانزل له
الشفاء من عندك يا رب
العالمين واعلموا ان الله سبحانه وتعالى
امركم بامر بدا به بنفسه فقال جل من قائل
ان الله وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها
الذين امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا تسليما
اللهم صل وسلم على عبدك ورسولك محمد ورضى
اللهم عن الخلفاء الراشدين المهديين وعن
بقيه الصحابه وعن التابعين ومن تبعهم
باحسان الى يوم الدين وعنا معهم بعفوك
وكرمك واحسانك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم اعز
الاسلام والمسلمين واذل الشرك والمشركين
ودمر اعداءك اعداء
الدين اللهم ثبتنا على قولك الثابت في
الحياه الدنيا وفي الاخره ربنا لا تزغ
قلوبنا بعد اذ هديتنا وهب لنا من لدنك
رحمه انك انت الوهاب واصلح اللهم احوالنا
في الامور كلها واختم اللهم بالصالحات
اعمالا وبسعاده اجالنا وتوفنا يا رب
العالمين وانت راض عنا اللهم اجعل اللهم
اجعل جمعنا هذا جمعا مباركا مرحوما
وتفرقنا تفرقا معصوما ربنا لا تدع لنا
ذنبا الا غفرته ولا هما الا فرجته ولا
مريضا الا شفيته ولا ميتا الا رحمته واغفر
اللهم لنا ولوالدينا ولاخواننا ولجميع من
سبقنا بالايمان واتنا من لدنك رحمه وهيئ
لنا من من امرنا رشدا اللهم اتنا في
الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار ان الله يامركم بالعدل ان الله يامر
بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذ القربى وينهى عن
الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون فاذكروا الله العظيم الجليل يذكركم
واشكروه على نعمه يزدكم ولذكر الله اكبر
والله يعلم ما تصنعون
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه حيا على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووا واستقيم وديل تواصوا يرحمكم الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا زلزلت الارض
زلزالها
واخرجت الارض
اثقالها وقال
الانسان ما
لها
يومئذ تحدث
اخبارها
بان ربك اوحى
لها
يومئذ يصدر
الناس
اشته ليروا
اعمالهم
فمن يعمل مثقال ذره
خيرا
يره فمن يعمل مثقال
ذره شرا
يره ومن يعمل مثقال
ذره خيرا
يره فمن يعمل مثقال ذره
خيرا
يره ومن يعمل مثقال
ذره شرا
يرى الله
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليه ولا الضالين
[Silence]
امين اذا
جاء نصر الله
والفتح ورايت
الناس يدخلون في د دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفر
انه كان
تبا الله ا
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏time
‏pass
[Silence]
‏or at least donate for that c you canay
for the whole day or for any
ofal any day so brother j is going to be
one of the coordinators who can help us
with that if you have you can schedule
on the wall over there in the back you
can put the name in there if you want to
don paral just put in there something
number we can contact you
andin but not least academy
[Silence]
ء
كم